all right the Democrats election
playbook is now in full swing according
to the left if you support Donald Trump
or you have conservative opinions you're
no longer a decent human being instead
according to them you're xenophobic
Islamophobic homophobic racist sexist
misogynist you want dirty hair you want
dirty water you definitely want to take
grandma and throw a right over the cliff
and by the way you want children to die
oh and by the way we are these smelly
Walmart shoppers the irredeemable
deplorable z' you know we're the people
that cling to our God our guns our
Bibles and religion now this is
especially true during the age of Trump
now we've seen the president's allies
kicked out of restaurants shouted down
on the street harassed in front of their
own homes front yards and the most
vicious attacks even against women and
even against the president's children
and grandchildren so it's no surprise
that our own judge Jeanine Pirro
was not warmly welcome during her guest
appearance on the view on ABC by the way
Disney are you proud of this
take a look here's my question for you
I'm not Joe buddy oh yeah did you just
point at me yeah listen I don't have
Trampas arrangement there have been a
lot of people in office that I didn't
agree with but I have never ever seen
anything like this I've never seen
anybody whip up such hate I've never
seen anybody be so how long is the deep
state been there and who's running it
well I won't answer your question
because you getting statement which is
how horrible it is a Donald Trump be
here murdering the children of Americans
so you know what's hard whatsoever when
the president we united nation
to beat the hell out of him now alright
SPO I spoke with judge Pierrot right
after that appearance they got much
worse backstage and she will join us
tonight in just a moment with a lot more
and of course for the entire week the
left's anti-trump echo chamber has been
on super super duper high alert now the
president's meeting with Vladimir Putin
has been compared let's see to the
Holocaust Pearl Harbor 9/11 and the
rhetoric has been absolutely psychotic
from page of The New Yorker look at this
featuring a cartoon showing a dead
president Trump face down at the bottom
of an escalator great his kids have to
see that his grandkids have to see that
and Time magazine featuring this
ominous-looking putin trump hybrid and
by the way on TV over just the past 24
hours alone not the earlier 48 hours the
anti Trump hysteria is even worse
they're all in a state of panic the
economy is doing well we're safer than
we've been and they know they're gonna
lose the next election they're scared
take a look did the president share
classified information with Putin did
the president take other steps beyond
those that it took so publicly to
undermine the security of the United
States this president is very happy
making himself a client of Vladimir
Putin who knows what they talked about
behind closed doors he's aiding and
abetting the enemy I can't believe this
is something I'm saying about the
president the United States but it made
me wonder if people are suspicious that
he revealed sensitive classified
intelligence including human source
information to the President of the
Russian Federation what Putin does is
exactly what Trump does or what Trump
does is what Putin does which is they
they lie for a living shaky as I have
felt since the night he won back then my
biggest fear was we had elected an asset
of the Russian government who would sell
out America at every opportunity just to
save his own hide
my biggest fear now is that I was right
all right just might we just saw
president Trump has a long track record
countering the malicious actions of
Vladimir Putin something that President
Obama did not have now the president
armed Ukraine he increased sanctions on
rusha he increased funding at NATO he
slapped severe financial restrictions on
some of Latimer Putin's closest allies
he authorized a counter-attack and as
Putin was backing soldiers inside a
Syria killing hundreds of Russians and
remember Russia's remember the hostile
takeover in Crimea in Ukraine
well Putin's power grab in Syria and all
this election meddling you're hearing so
much about it all happened on Obama's
watch he was the president just like
giving Putin 20% of America's uranium
that was on Obama's watch so the
foundational material for nuclear
weapons was given to Putin and Russia
the bad actor the hostile regime while
Obama was president nobody in the media
mentioned this all week now you think
you'll hear about this if you turn on
conspiracy TV MSNBC fake news CNN I tend
to doubt it so today President Trump
once again he reiterated his commitment
to countering Putin he issued a very
stern warning this is what we call peace
through strength judge for yourself take
a look look at the sanctions I put on
look at the diplomats I threw out look
at all of the things that I've done
nobody else did what I've done Obama
didn't do it
Obama was a patsy for Russia he was a
total patsy look at this statement he
made when he thought the mics were
turned off okay
the stupid statement he made nobody does
a big deal about that getting along with
President Putin getting along with
Russia's a positive not a negative right
now with that being said if that doesn't
work out I'll be the worst enemy he's
ever had that doesn't work out he'll be
the worst enemy he's ever had but for
the sake of the world our kids let's
hope it works out and while the media is
obsessing about Russia Russia Russia I'd
like to remind the so-called journalists
that it's a very big world out there
there's a lot of complex issues in this
world and maybe just maybe Russia isn't
even our biggest international foe now
let's listen to what the FBI director
Christopher Rey said yesterday China
from a counterintelligence perspective
in many ways represents the
broadest most challenging most
significant threat we face as a country
and I say that because for them it is a
whole of state effort it is economic
espionage as well as traditional
espionage
it is non-traditional collectors as well
as traditional intelligence operatives
its human sources as well as cyber means
it we have economic espionage
investigations in every state all 50
states that trace back to China that's
right China not Russia all right someone
may want to tell the left in this
country that there's more to life than
Vladimir Putin so why isn't the media
obsessing about the China threat where's
the hysteria over Chinese hacking and
aggressive military actions in the
Pacific currency manipulation theft of
intellectual property while the left is
spinning out of control over Russia
Russia all right here on Hannity we
report the full story
president Trump is keenly aware that the
geopolitical threat that is posed by all
of these bad actors including China and
has long called them out in a very
public way take a look just remember
with a bank where the bank that
everybody wants to steal from and
plunder and it can't be that way anymore
we lost five hundred billion dollars
last year with China we are going to end
the theft of American intellectual
property crackdown on China's trade
abuses and confront countries that cheat
I also had a very candid conversation
with President Xi about the need to
reduce our staggering trade deficit with
China and for our trading relationship
to be conducted on a truly fair and
equitable basis we can no longer
tolerate unfair trading practices that
steal American jobs wealth and
intellectual property and as usual the
president's words are backed up with
tough action crippling tariffs upgrading
missile defense systems to China's
neighbors reaffirming America's
commitments to Taiwan and turning the
screws on North Korea I'll have more on
the
president and the president's
geopolitical peace through strength
strategy throughout the show tonight but
first we've got to turn to a very
shocking story it should make your blood
boil
you know the sanctuary city of San
Francisco they're now spitting in the
face of every single law-abiding
American tonight city officials and now
permitting illegal immigrants other non
citizens to register to vote in
November's election that's right you can
literally you can't make this up they're
allowing this barring any future legal
action illegal immigrants will now be
among those in San Francisco who get to
vote in certain local elections now this
is just one more obvious sign that the
left in this country they don't care
about the rule of law our Constitution
about the rights of the many they don't
believe in borders they have no agenda
to improve America instead they want to
regain power at all costs well for 2018
it's simple they want their crumbs back
they want to rescind the tax cuts they
want to impeach Trump but they're trying
to tell everybody not to say it publicly
they want to preserve Obama's legacy
keep your doctor plan and pay less they
want Obamacare to stay they want to
block the president's Supreme Court
choices and the confirmation of justice
Cavanaugh and that's right you can see
it they want open borders also they're
not proposing one thing that'll solve
any problem for any American citizen it
is without a doubt the most important
midterm election in our lifetime the
future of this country is at stake they
want to undo the 2016 election and
finally tonight we do have a breaking
news story from John Solomon he's
highlighting an underreported text from
the corrupt FBI investigator Peter
struck to his girlfriend Lisa page now
the text reads an investigation leading
to impeachment you and I both know the
odds are nothing and struck goes on and
he says quote there's no big there there
now the timing of this text is
incredibly telling it's just two days
after Robert Muller was appointed to
conduct this witch hunt on Trump Russia
collusion and according to Solomon while
Peter struck refused to answer what this
text was referring to lisa page
closed doors did in fact confirm that
the text referred to the quality of the
russia case that he was leading so
there's no big there there and there
never was and here we are four hundred
and twenty eight days later millions of
dollars later this never-ending divide
and fishing expedition rolls on show us
the evidence mr. Muller you know and
your pit bull Andrew Weissman why did
you ever appointed guy that had that
much corruption in his background really
withholding exculpatory evidence beaten
Dino in the Supreme Court sending
innocent people to jail for a year
overturned by the Fifth Circuit tens of
thousands of Americans lost their job
he's your number one guy
really and then you can't find a single
Republican to put on your team not one
just a merry band of Hillary supporters
and Democratic donors